- I'm gonna end on a lighter note Nikolaj.
(laughing)
- Yes.
- Because I know that you speak Danish
and I,
I literally just released a song
in like six different
languages and I love languages,
but I've never spoken one word in Danish,
I believe.
So I was wondering if you could teach me
to say something in Danish that's easy.
- Something that's easy.
Any, any preferences,
anything you want to know?
- I mean,
I mean, how would I,
how would I say, like,
could I, could I please
have an Apple Danish?
Is that really hard?
- No, you say
(speaking in Danish)
Perfect.
Fantastic.
(laughing)
(speaking in Danish)
That's a difficult one.
- With a (speaking in Danish)
(laughing)
Okay, I tried.
I'm gonna learn it
and the next time I'm gonna frickin'
learn how to say that and
it's gonna be so effortless
the next time I see you.
And then you better have an Apple Danish.
Okay.
- I will.